does the changing climate offer up
tunities unexpected opportunities so for
example there is a national debate going
on about whether people should even go
to college and whether snobs we're snobs
so all of us are at a university getting
undergraduate degrees or advanced
degrees or our graduates so obviously as
a person who's curious as you said
passionately about higher education this
debate would trouble you I would think
as it as an institution how do you
interact when the climate is changing
around us in the in these kinds of ways
it is a troubling a troubling situation
but you know with every troubling
situation there is also an opportunity
and I think the dimension or the comment
that we heard recently that it is not
wish to you know aspire to a university
or college degree is a different facet
of another question that has been around
for a longer time and that is why should
I give to a wealthy institution and Yale
happens to be above the institution so
this is a question that we have heard a
lot that we have heard you know from in
primarily from individuals who really
are not involved and lack a certain
understanding of you know what private
institutions are about so you know how
do you think about you know why should
you give to Yale it's so wealthy could
do anything it wants to do i think if
you there is somewhere in there a
legitimate question and the legitimate
question in there is tell us what you do
with your wealth tell us you know are
you using your wealth for the public
good are you using your wealth to do
something good in society or are you
squandering it by i don't know doing
what with it now when you when you look
at the question from that
this you know it becomes a lot easier to
explain why people should give to an
institution like Yale others first of
all you can start out there are two
models of funding higher education right
public and private so you look at what
what you know you compare the two
systems and what's striking is in every
survey that you read you know that ranks
institutions you have to go through 20
institutions at least to come to the
first public institution the last survey
it was ranked number 22 it was Berkeley
only then do public institutions begin
to now look at Berkeley that's an
incredibly interesting situation
berkeley and the California State
University system was the treasure of
higher education of public higher
education and some from you are from
California so you know what's happening
there when the political climate shifts
when budgets get tied you know people
don't hesitate to cut higher education
and what what the california state
system is going through right now is
really tragic because it was such a
stellar you know system now this systems
you know so a subject to you know the
vagaries of political you know
developments the bakery's of economic
development on the private side you know
the individuals decided who founded this
institution said you know I'm going to
rely on myself I'm going to rely on a
different system i'm going to start up
this institution then i charge something
out to those people who want to be here
but then I
they want that everybody who graduates
understands that you know they have an
opportunity maybe even a little bit of a
moral obligation but at least an
opportunity to to hand over this
institution to the next generation in a
better way so that the institution is
better off and that's what endowments
are and diamonds are nothing but gifts
that were given and are well managed so
you know an institution like Yale with
the big endowment it has is capable of
playing a much more impactful of
impactful role than other institutions
you know when you look at advances in
science it costs money you know 300
years ago nobody talked about gene
sequencing well today if you want to be
a player you have to do that but through
these advances and through investment in
science this is also what fuels the
economic development economic health of
our country you know and aside from the
fact that you know it's always good to
educate people who are capable of
providing good leadership when they go
out in the world and then one thing I
just want to mention too that is you
know the private institutions have been
a major factor in social mobility
because when you think about it
sometimes it is less expensive to come
to a place like Yale or and private
institution than to go to a public
institution why because philanthropists
donors have understand that and have
given a lot of money to financial aid